Let me remind you that the David Pakman show
is mostly funded by people who sign up and
join Patman dot com.
Everyone is welcome regardless of age, regardless
of national origin. You can sign up from anywhere
in the world and people regularly do. And
it is the primary funding source for our program.
So consider yourselves invited. You will get
the award winning awards we give out, but
still award winning bonus show every single
day, as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show at Join Pacman dot
com. Let's see what's on the minds of some
of our viewers and listeners. We are going
to go to the phone lines at six one seven
eight three zero. Forty seven fifty. Starting
with our caller from the two one four area
code. Caller from two one four. What's your
name and where are you calling from?
Hello, dating one once. I'm trying to get
you back were.
OK, you there? I'm here.
Hey, this is Dave calling from Dallas, Texas.
And thank you for taking my call. Yeah. So
whenever people get on unemployment, they
typically don't get their full paycheck. I
think they get something like 60 or 70 percent.
So when I heard the first heard that they
were going to be given an extra 600 dollars
to people on unemployment, I assume they were
going to give people the difference between,
you know, their paycheck and you know what?
They would've gotten on unemployment up to
a maximum of six hundred dollars. Right. So
I was pretty shocked when I heard they were
going to give everybody an extra six hundred
dollars. And I think right now they're looking
at maybe even extending that. So I think the
better use of that money would be to, of course,
give unemployed people there the equivalent
of their full paycheck, but then use the rest
of that money to maybe help small business
owners and the self-employed, who in many
cases have seen their income drop dramatically
and in some cases had it taken away completely
because they were forced to shut down entirely.
So I'm just wondering if you think that's
the best use.
Well, so remember, Dave, that it turns out
that there was money left over in the P p
p fund as far as I most recently saw. So there
was actually, you know, you're at your idea
of taking some money out of unemployment and
giving it to small businesses. Small businesses
didn't even scoop up the money that was available.
So it's unclear to me that that's really the
solution. Now, what it sounds like your concern
is, and I understand the concern, it's should
anybody be making more on unemployment than
by working? That seems to be the fundamental
concern you have, right.
No, actually, it's not my fundamental concern
is that with the PDP program, that's that's
really helping the employees as well. Only
75 percent of the PDP line has to be used
to pay your employees. That's correct. That
business owners only get 25 percent. So there's
the business on the only help that the government
is offering, offering business owners this
debt in the form of low interest SBA loans
and maybe helping you with 25 percent on your
rent or your utilities.
Yeah, I mean, a lot of a lot of that is forgivable,
remember. So it's not it's not alone in practice.
But I think I'm now better understanding what
you're saying, which is the PDP will allow
you to keep your employees on and pay them,
but it doesn't generate demand necessarily
for what you're selling and your business
revenue may be in the tank. What if some of
the money could be used for that instead?
Yeah. But, you know, I guess what I'm talking
about, too, is things like, you know, the
guy who used to cut my hair, I used to cut
my hair. I'm not going to get my hair cut.
Yeah, right. His business has gone off dramatically.
I know a lady who's who has a event planning
business. She has literally no business now.
Right now, she. Her business is gone. My wife,
for example, owns a pet sitting company. Pet
shelters depend on people traveling or having
to go to a job every day. And even her dog
taken up a military base. Her business is
down 70 percent right now.
So now, David, a really good you know that
over from that government.
I know your concern as sole proprietors here.
I don't know if you knew, but the unemployment
benefits were expanded to include sole proprietors
and people who work for themselves who normally
would not qualify for unemployment. And I
think that that's important as well. I don't
know if you knew that.
I did not know that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So
I actually called my representatives and asked
them what they were doing to help people like
my wife.
Yeah. And I've been just told basically about
the BPP loan. And I point out, John, well,
that's really not for the year. That's really
for the employees mostly, right?
No, I know. I know. Like, for example, I know
I know social media consultants who just work
for themselves, who have gone on unemployment
and they would not normally be able to. But
but they were I mean, listen, the details
are are in some cases not perfect. But overall,
the situation is a mess. I don't think that
the government has done nearly enough when
you compare us to other countries. But it
seems like, you know, on the details, we could
certainly talk about it all day.
Yeah, well, let me ask you one more thing.
Do you think that that actually that this
whole 600 extra dollars actually kind of feeds
into the conservative narrative that Democrats
are socialists who want to pay people not
to work? That's another thing about it. I
will say.
Well, it's the Trump administration who did
it, and it's Trump who said that he was very
much in favor of it. So. So I guess this is
Trump the socialist is what I would say to
them.
But I agree with you.
I'm just saying that's that's what that's
what our conservatives about spin that they're
not going to say Trump's associates.
Well, then I'd say I'd tell him, if you don't
like it, vote Trump out, cause Trump's the
guy who did it.
But I don't agree with that. That's actually
a good comeback on that. And before I let
you go, can I just make one other quick comment?
Yeah. Something I've been hearing you and
a lot of other people say. Sure. I keep hearing
people say that Biden has to win in a landslide,
that this has to be a decisive victory. You
know, in my lifetime, I don't think I've ever
heard Republicans say they have to win in
a landslide. I don't think they think they
have to win. They just think they have to
convince us that they won by at least one
vote. I think it's great to say we have to
win a landslide. Maybe you guys should also
thought with the caveat that at the end of
the day, just like the Republicans, all we
have to do is win, even if it's only about
one vote.
I agree with you. We only have to win by one
vote. It would be better to prevent Trump
from doing more of his shenanigans to win
by more than one vote. But you're completely
right. You only need to win by one. All right,
Dave from Dallas, thank you for the call.
I appreciate it. Lot of a lot of important
issues there